y esta historia empieza cuando tengo 8
años creo que se hace cuando no se
empieza como acordar las cosas en la
vida
soy parte de una familia de clase media
típica viajamos por carretera
vamos cuatro personas en la parte de
atrás del carro espicha dijimos además
esto hace mucho tiempo y ya no había
autopistas ni doble calzada doble carril
ni nada
y entonces los viajes eran larguísimos
elegir un viaje que hoy se demoraría dos
horas antes eran de cuatro horas y se
llevara una mula grande seis horas
entonces estábamos todos ahí metidos muy
aburridos
pero
en los momentos en los que jugábamos a
veces jugamos un juego muy particular
poco a poco
y vamos contando los molinos de viento
que iban en la carretera o contábamos
los burros y molinos de viento o burros
el que primero veía uno de esos con mis
hermanos y ganaba iba ganando puntos y
puntos los molinos voy a pasar un poco
los molinos
valían dos puntos y los burros valían un
punto y estará el sistema con el que
nosotros nos nos manejábamos este juego
con dinamarca tiene dos ejes viales
principales uno que va al occidente
generalmente a girar dos nos los vamos a
girar dona a un pueblo
a un hotel que existía en la época y el
del norte y nos guiamos a país vacantes
en boyacá salíamos por cundinamarca pero
esa eran nuestros vecinos fijos y no
miramos para otro lado un día
cuando tenía como ocho años me acuerdo
de preguntarlo para que era ni siquiera
dije pnd y 13 dije que es pan de 3 y
obviamente se rieron todos pero yo había
visto esa señal que decía pandi 13
esta es la entrada hoy con google maps
no pueden mirar dónde queda hoy la
entrada para andy es el lugar y pasaron
32 años de mi vida viajando ha girado
constantemente y nunca nunca entré
aparte
nunca veía el letrero me fijaba me
acordaba de la época pero nunca entré a
pnd y bueno pasó el tiempo y cinco años
atrás hace cinco años igual yo con mi
novia que después se convertiría mi
esposa era de hecho una costeña
cartagenera de esas que cree que es el
cachaco pues es una enfermedad incurable
y de pronto
y bueno además ella es muy buena persona
pero es de esas típicas novias que no se
quieren quedar en un hotel incómodo que
si no las lleva a un lugar feo protestan
pero bueno pero de pronto sencillo una
urgencia y sentí si me vino el
sentimiento que más me gusta en la vida
tal vez el sentimiento que más
transforma la humanidad la determinación
había una señal que decía turmequé y
digamos pero decía turmequé y dije voy a
voltear no me pregunten porque me volteé
para turmequé y empezamos a subir
yo estaba que me decía pipí ya no podía
más de las ganas y llegamos después de
45 minutos a turmequé
pero yo no lo hice por todo ello lo hice
por pan y si lo hicieron ahora pnd y esa
era mi obsesión ya tengo tengo tengo que
hacerle a la pandilla y yo no quiero
pasar otros 35 años de mi vida en el
puesto tiene 35 no quiero que pase
nosotros es de 5 años más de mi vida sin
entrar a pnd y sin entrar a los pueblos
olvidado y hablar con su gente
entonces ahí tuve una idea decidí
visitar todos los pueblos de colombia
todos sin excepción uno por uno
y hay mi primer aprendizaje uno a veces
no tiene las ideas las ideas como que lo
tienen a uno uno no sabe dónde le salen
bueno yo estaba próximo a casarme con la
persona que fui que estaba de viaje
estaba próximo a casarme porque nos
íbamos a ir a inglaterra a estudiar yo
había decidido tomarme cinco años
de estudio digamos como para volver a
resentir la mente volver a entender cómo
es que es la cosa
y cuando no se casan o si se les ha
pasado a los que se casan a mí me pasó
el día anterior de casarse el padre
tiene uno tiene una charla con uno el
historia usted si va a ser feliz con esa
persona van a poder cumplir los sueños
yo le dije sin padre si ella me prometió
que yo voy a que yo a su lado voy a
poder visitar todos los pueblos de
colombia y que ella me vaya me va a
acompañar algunos yo creí firmemente yo
creí porque estamos delante de un padre
y yo le dije que me ha prometido y así
pasó la cosa al año y medio nos
separamos
pero la idea seguía absolutamente
intacta
y ahí mi segundo aprendizaje las ideas
no lo abandonan a uno
pero y yo estando en este lugar en una
biblioteca muy formal y usando las
fotocopias o los papeles de apuntes en
esas horas largas de biblioteca que no
se dormía empecé a dibujar lo que podría
ser esta idea
primero tiene que buscar el número de
municipios que hay en colombia.y mi
número fue 11 23 siempre que digo este
número alguien sin hacer que después me
si no no no no son mil 102 mil 109
digamos si es que existe está polémica
pero por favor esta vez no lo hagan
y ya hice mi tarea y son mil 102
municipios 20 corregimientos
departamentales y el distrito capital
11 23 mil 123 municipios que visitan
como voy a llamar la idea entonces
decidí proyecto 1123 muy simple un
hashtag proyecto 123 me siento interés y
allí tras el aprendizaje y es que a las
personas a las ideas como las personas
hay que nombrar las es un derecho de las
ideas ser nombradas
cuál es el concepto en este momento cuál
es el concepto pues yo estaba estudiando
en un ambiente muy académico y dije voy
a hacer una maestría cuyo tema es
colombia pero esa maestría no sucede en
los salones yo hoy le pregunto a unos
profesores en alguna universidad
prestigiosa o en algunas universidades
de región
unas preguntas de investigación en estos
campos economía cultura geografía y
medio ambiente agarra maestría una
pregunta investigación y una disculpa de
leer literatura pero yo ni valer
simplemente iba a contestar esas
preguntas hablando con la gente de todos
los pueblos de colombia
cuando tiempo me gasto hay siempre yo
las matemáticas alegres yo lo quería
hacer en un año pues porque digamos no
podía estar más más tiempo fuera del
trabajo yo soy una persona que vive de
mi trabajo de mi trabajo empecé a hacer
las cuentas alegres y dije finalmente
voy a gastar un año y medio porque hay
unos municipios que son muy difíciles de
llegar pues en tres municipios por día
hay algunos que toca llegar en canoa
entonces dije bueno un año y medio es
una cifra posible cuánto me cuesta lo
mismo las matemáticas del optimista
empecé a hacerme empezar misma temática
se dirige con 152 millones de pesos
puedo hacer esto
y como lo voy a financiar pues de manera
muy sencilla pensé yo con minutos de
vídeos los minutos de vídeos los paga
las entidades públicas a dos millones de
pesos por minuto
yo las puedo vender a 200.000 y solo
necesito 679 minutos voy a estar
muchísimo más vasta como 67 mil minutos
en los pueblos con que me salgan nada
más 670 estoy al otro lado
volví del sitio que estaba estudiando
porque me faltaba estudiar un poco más
la segunda maestría
yo he aplicado a la universidad pero
pues no me podía ir si no me dan una
beca porque estaba realmente vaciado si
tenía ni idea pero estaba absolutamente
vaciado los estudiantes viviendo los
vaciados no me compraba yo unos unos
tenis y unos jeans así no sé cuánto
tiempo y no puedo más y de pronto dije
bueno voy a aplicar esta beca a la
universidad y use esta idea como el
ensayo para aplicar a la beca hace dos
meses me respondió la universidad de
harvard kim era una beca para estudiar
una maestría en administración pública
porque yo empecé a tener la idea de que
esto lo podía usar para empezar a
informar a la administración de los
problemas de la gente
y ahí entonces mi cuarta el cuarto
aprendizaje
si uno estira las ideas las ideas son
fieles a uno y le abren camino
exactamente el mismo día y esto está
llena de coincidencias van a ver
exactamente el mismo día me llama la
persona con la que lleva saliendo solo
tres meses con una relación bonita en
unos sentidos y mala en otros porque yo
me iba a ir dentro de muy poco esas
relaciones y me dicen que estamos
embarazados y en eso le pido por favor
que nos sigan mi ejemplo a los jóvenes
que están aquí en este auditorio
pero de todos modos llegó llegó esta
noticia y yo me puse feliz soy optimista
patológico y me puse feliz decidimos
tener lo que vamos a ver que nos
inventamos y nos fuimos los tres a la
boston a la maestría ya en harvard
empecé a mezclar lo que ya tenía de idea
con dos cosas más la primera el
pensamiento de diseño es una estrategia
o una metodología para diseñar productos
y servicios o cosas en general cuyo
principal punto es la empatía
y hablar con la gente para tener los
problemas reales que tiene las personas
y eso se deriva el diseño centrada del
humano y diseñar las puertas para
humanos o para edificios y no se diseña
la puerta para que alguien pueda abrir
para que personas con discapacidad
puedan entrar
y me enganché si soy sincero y si algo
se les va a quedar hoy es esto me
enganché con la empatía con la
posibilidad tener conversaciones reales
con las personas y entender cuáles son
sus problemas
y me enganché que una pregunta que me
dio un profesora ya hice la mejor
pregunta es dime más cuéntame más los
políticos llegan siempre a los pueblos a
ellos hablar no hay que llegar a oír y
la mejor pregunta es dime más
y de toda esta mezcla surgió un concepto
que hoy el proyecto se llama políticas
públicas centradas en el humano como el
diseño pero ahora las políticas públicas
centradas en los seres humanos
y ahí surge el segundo nombre el cambio
de nombre y siempre va a llamar el
proyecto la escuela de la empatía
todavía un proyecto una idea se empezó a
llamar la escuela de la empatía y esa
era mi propósito viajar aparecido en un
bus aa tener esas conversaciones
y darles el mismo viaje pero teniendo
una mayor cantidad de conversaciones
posibles y entender la realidad de la
gente y que alguien haga algo para
influir en las políticas públicas y ahí
mi quinto aprendizaje y es que las ideas
no son estáticas las ideas evolucionan y
no le tiene que dar el derecho a las
ideas de que evolucionen poco a poco
acción no está mal
e
de pronto falta un mes para que nazca mi
hijo y empieza la familia con esta idea
yo estaba aprendiendo todo para volver y
hacerla realidad y de pronto que empieza
todo el mundo pero es que usted lleva
cinco años sin trabajar va a tener un
hijo que va a ser y la cosa se empieza
como a complicar y uno empieza realmente
tener una duda si te será que debo
seguir gastando el tiempo esto o empezar
a buscar trabajo en normal
y ahí mi sexo aprendizaje y es que las
ideas a veces lo confrontan a uno y lo
miden el eminem a uno que tan valiente
es uno
y yo dije necesito una señal que le voy
a delegar esto a al destino que necesito
una señal que si debo hacer esto y
adivinen qué día nació juan pedro
nació
el 11 23 nació el 23 de noviembre de
2016 nació juan pedro y que además mi
mamá me contó que era el día que había
nacido un hermano mío que se murió
chiquito y yo no sabía que había nacido
ese día dije pues ahí tengo la señal no
tengo más que decir
pero obviamente tampoco soy yo bruto y
dije tengo que ser responsable juan pero
cuando realmente llegó dije soy
responsable de esa vida entonces dije
qué pasa si hago como los emprendedores
iloílo
y lo pasamos a genera un producto mínimo
viable
y entonces
y mi séptimo aprendizaje y es que las
ideas pueden partir si nos dan miedo
pues las hacemos paso a paso como todo
en la vida
cundinamarca 116
aquí ya empecé a dar muchísima más forma
a la idea estaba en la universidad
entonces cogí dividir el territorio con
dinamarca en 12 rutas en 11 rutas
conseguí 10 amigos y empezamos a
estudiar cómo era la cosa y se acuerdan
de los molinos y de los burros pues esos
son datos y entonces este vídeo también
cogió un carácter muy importante y es
que vamos a ir recogiendo datos por
todas las partes a mapear dónde están
los molinos dónde están los puentes los
hospitales y así vamos creando un mapa
que le permita a la misión pública a
gestionar el terreno
y empezaron a pasar estas cosas esta es
una influencia muy importante un
personaje más ricardo hausmann un
venezolano de la universidad que hace
este tipo de cosas con los datos y a mí
me entró ese amor por los datos y dije
empatía más datos
esto es esta la fórmula la empatía malos
datos entonces hicimos nuestros propios
prototipos en google maps hicimos
nuestros formularios en google forms
usan dos cosas gratis y esto es por
ahora es voluntad no era no era nada no
costaba pero como es el exponencial cómo
hacer que más gente viaje porque yo
recogiendo datos de uno en uno no va a
terminar nunca entonces cómo hacer que
mucha gente más viaje y entonces me puse
a pensar cómo convencerlos y que a la
gente le gusta viajar le gusta conectar
esos como como dos cosas comunes a la
gente le gusta viajar
y entonces surgió este concepto que se
llama turismo de políticas públicas que
a la larga es irse de paseo pero por un
segundo no se ponen las gafas de decir
uno va a lorica
y además de fijarse que es el lugar de
alves de los lugares de la tierra ese
mercado no tiene comparación en ninguna
parte del mundo pero no se fija un poco
cómo vive la gente qué problemas tienen
y entonces apenas tiene esa calidad le
entrega esa información a alguien que sí
puede hacer algo le entrega los
hallazgos a alguien que puede hacer algo
y aquí también un tema muy importante
una estadística puede ser la gasolina el
emprendimiento social aórtica decían yo
cuando cuando hace unos años vio la
estadística que decía el 96% del
municipio del país no tiene sala de cine
sólo con esa estadística fue gasolina
suficiente para decir esto es injusto y
tengo que ser un proyecto para llevarle
al cine a los pueblos y yo creo que a
cada persona y a cada emprendedor social
les llega su estadística esa cosa que
uno no se aguanta que pase
de la vida entonces escoger todos esos
datos esas conversaciones ponerlas en
una plataforma de datos abiertos para
que mucha gente las pueda hacer e ir
escribiendo derechos de petición como un
loco si uno ve un problema está una
plantilla de derecho de petición lista y
uno ve el problema y le escribe
inmediatamente en aplicación escribe
inmediatamente la petición se crea un
pdf y se manda por un correo electrónico
para poder influir en las políticas
públicas a través de los derechos de
petición
pero un día de buscar la plata para
hacer esto y dije yo que hago hablando
de esto como don quijote sin haberlo
vivido y si no podría estar hoy parado
aquí con la legitimidad suficiente si yo
no lo hubiera intentado primero y si no
hubiera dicho que esto era posible
porque estaba de esa carreta seamos
sinceros entonces y obtengo aprendizaje
las ideas hay que vivirlas saber cómo
son las que saben
suficiente teoría cinco años después de
haberme desviado en tour me que
emprendía el viaje
busque un compañero del viejo juan si
una persona sin la que no hubiera podido
ser esto posible que el toma las fotos
me da ánimo es buenísimo con la gente yo
a veces estoy cansado pero él respeta a
las personas se le da la dignidad al
campesino una persona muchísima mejor
persona que yo
y ahí el buen aprendizaje y es que las
ideas son mejor cuando no las comparte
no importa a quién se le ocurrió hay que
armar parche las ideas son muchísimo
mejor compartidas ese es el primer peaje
el 17 de marzo de 2018
estos son los viajes que llevamos estas
son las fotos y las imágenes que uno se
va llevando y lo van enriqueciendo en la
vida
conversaciones en lugares inesperados
lugares que yo nunca ha ido nuevas
estéticas
la belleza de los pueblos y la violencia
de colombia que define igualable las
personas
los viejos del campo se están venciendo
muchísimo es una de las principales
conclusiones de las que del que va
llevando el campo se está envejeciendo
los trabajadores
y ha sido un aprendizaje de eso es que
uno le digamos que cambia la vida
y miren dónde llegamos
llegamos a pando
llegamos a para mí cuando yo dice de
verdad no podía creerlo y llegamos a pnd
y el inicio no va a ese niño que
preguntó que dónde que haga pan llevamos
63 de los 116 municipios
llamamos a los 63 de los 116 pero lo
siento y 6 son el 10% de colombia cuando
hagamos esto ya llevamos el 10 por
ciento entonces me voy a animar a hacer
el resto pues ya llegó el 10 por ciento
un poquitico más de gasolina o el llegar
yo al cien por ciento
pero como sólo es una fracción
necesitamos definitivamente ayuda
y por eso quiero preguntar y terminado y
diciéndoles o preguntándoles ciencia
ánimas en el proyecto córdoba 30
en una mano
dos manos tres manos cuatro manos
athletic hablamos lo que realmente
necesitamos ayuda muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
i